en ce 1er avril nous consacrons notre
page spéciale aux championnats d'europe
de ski les curés et oui le trophée des
ecclésiastiques que célèbre cette année
sa 35e édition ils sont plus de 100 curé
prêtre au départ de cette course c'était
ce matin à serre-chevalier
ils viennent de france d'italie et de
suisse notamment
reportage sur les pistes avec elle bon
nicosie et jean-françois ans j'ai dit
bien sûr le style n'est pas toujours
très orthodoxe mais comme dans chaque
course il ya les favoris et les mois
c'est si j'arrive je parlais des
derniers c'est bon pour moi dernier
entraînement ce matin et premières
impressions devant nous plusieurs la
blague les palmes aux caves du ski au
départ bien sûr les skieurs ont fuit
leur âme à dieu et éventuellement au
saint bernard de la station et c'est
parti pour trois km de parcours
chronométré
un mois avant l'ascension le clergé fait
en quelque sorte la descente géant
google permet de prendre un peu de temps
pour la 33e édition de ce challenge très
particulier une rumeur parcourt et ce
matin et les ventes d'ici fromage du
pays
elle faisait état de l'éventuelle venue
de jean paul ii demain pour le slalom
une discipline qu'il pratique paraît-il
très bien j'ai entendu dire qu'il était
assez bon skieur
on pensait le voir aujourd'hui mais bon
peut-être peut-être qu'il viendra demain
pour la course
en attendant les meilleurs aligne les
kilomètres dans un style qui n'est pas
sans rappeler délicieusement le ski des
années 50